My glucose was 87, but my A1C was 4.5.4, which is not elevated, but it's kept up there.
Shouldn't my A1C be lower?
Not, you know, this is where, you know, dealing with blood glucose isn't as simple as I'm going to go on a diet.
Sugar in my blood glucose is going to go down my, he will go with A1C.
It might be elevated. That's a better indication of how your processing
glucose is, oh, the mucili is kind of cheese, but so it's the butterweight protocol.
I don't know, dairy was a driver. I think dairy was a driver, so I said no to it.
So I would say no to that.
So glucose at 87 is not too high, but what you're dealing with cancer.
And when you don't, if you had a really active cancer that you're trying to deal with, you really want your glucose to be lower than that.
But in your case, your cancer is in pretty much a state of remission.
So do you need to work actively to lower it?
Not necessarily.
But there are other things that you could do to help decrease your hemoglobin A1C.
Yes, from a nutritional standpoint, my first thought is burberry.
Chromium can help with that truth too.
So, and then look at your diet. If you're, you're, you're really clean.
I don't eat a lot of sugar and ODA and that stuff, but I wouldn't worry about it too much.
And if you have burberry, if you have picolidate, chromium picolidate at home, you can start taking some of that and see how that could help with your cell membranes.